il y a de ces blocs qui instantanément
nous rappelle notre enfance et nous
enveloppe de réconfort le pouding au riz
en fait partie a priori car c'est bien
faire rigoler les exceptionnels nous
avons rencontré le chef des miss un
pierrot centrale la nouvelle foire
gastronomique à montréal ici c'est très
multiethnique l'offre alimentaire donc
si on se promenait on pourrait trouver
plusieurs cuisiniers ici qu'il nous
ferait du coude et nourris à leur façon
on a une diaspora qui reflète bien ce
qui est la gastronomie montréalaise à
son ensemble je perçois des couples
phares voyage à tripoli
qu'est ce qui fait qu'on en or trouver
partout il du pouding au riz mais c'est
quelque chose qui est économique
juste une petite douceur crémeuse et
riche à la fin du repas je pense que le
récit promener le pouding au riz
d'arrivée mais ne vous publiez pas
chacun dans votre domaine vous contenter
de faire quelque chose de traditionnel
vous avez tous mis votre touche j'ai
bien compris notre tour du monde nous
emmène au laos alors en colombie en
passant par le maroc
mais nous aussi on dit sitôt faire un
riz au lait on l'appelle comme ça en
rigolait pas le polype ory on nous
considère comme un petit plat c'est
comme un petit souper léger chivot ça
ressemble à quoi colombie ça fait la
rose comme lecce qu'il traduit riollet
c'est vraiment une
héritage espagnol chaque famille comme
sa petite touche qui ajoute ça c'était
un dessert qui nous donnaient les
après-midi à la maison dans rentrant de
l'école c'était comme chacun sa petite
tasse de riz au lait et c'est comme ça
qu'ils en colombie du côté du l'asile à
tout le côté sud est asiatique on a le
riz au lait mais avec le lait de coco le
riz collant on le cuit le matin mais qu
est-ce qui s il remet dans le lait de
coco puis avec le mmm fraîche copilote
dimanche comme son principal ribéry à
l'asie ce très important on se lève le
matin au mans gilles lui me dit oh non
j'ai besoin vraiment et ça c'est la vie
power mais qu'en est il du classique de
notre enfance moi je veux réussir ça
comme ça shinobi nous avons navigué les
autres lignes on rit souvent sa bonne
série mais c'est facile a raté ses
quatre les bonnes proportions et moins
de mérite je pense
ok qu'est ce qu'on met la même pénurie
du lait moi je mets de la crème
parce que je terrain du riz du sucre les
prix du riz arborio céleri qu'on préfère
les risottos parce qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'un peu digne on vit de ça doit
avant le riz qui veut dégager 7
véhicules dans le lait et la crème
savoie l'épaisseur peut donner cette
belle texture convoitises de grands et
translucide
il est distinct se tient la crème et
soyeuse tous ceux sans ajout de fécule
de neuf ou de substituts dit pourquoi
l'art morio est préférable
il est rond il est plus résistant et le
plus de fécule même les raisins débats
traditionnels
ça a été patché ledent sirop d'érable cg
partie d'une casserole
j'ai mis mes raisins l'eau bouillie
gerin c'est mon dos le vieux secret
party l'érable est embarquée
[Musique]
bonjour d'année est-ce que la chose
puisqu'elle oui c'est ça qui nous
nourrit qui aurait cru que plat ou six
ans que faisait courir vous offre une
table aussi belle et colorée
vérifiez que ça va vous donner une
petite idée de ce à quoi la palette
canadienne
les érables sur des rames dans les
moi mourir ou laid c'est un riz cuit
dans le lait bien sur ces bases là mais
je cherchais je pensais alors diminués
évaporé avec un petit peu de sucre
branche à la cannelle et fleur d'oranger
et j'ai travaillé à cô té i marmelade
mandarine marocain avec l' orange et des
raisins du surtemps j'ai pris les
petites noix dame a visé un petit peu
pour donner le côté un petit peu
croquant sans oublier la menthe qu'ils
vraiment présente au maroc magnifique
entre les scènes
moi j'ai fait bien rigoler avec 2 les
scandales les stalles il apparaît aussi
parce que le nom de l'héritière jamais
en phase ou scadd pour rehausser et amba
jamie dulce de l'équipe mais à la façon
de la colombie qui s'appelle à l'équipe
est la différence entre elle et dulce de
leche et de l'argentine c'est que les
nôtres on les laisse courir plus de
temps alors c'est un peu plus
caramélisées j'ai mis en eau les filles
verte confie s'appelle bo et basse c'est
mènera bien c'est pas trop traditionnel
façon je le fais on est là pour que les
papilles s'amusant
alors ici j'ai pudding au lait de coco
infusé à lalime qui fait par la suite
j'ai pris des framboises juste boyer
avoir épongé très amérique du nord alors
je voulais ajouter d arracher du ca les
relevés au piment d'espelette la mangue
fraîche et mégane de cézembre mais à
l'époque nous les mamans faisait des
desserts avec du lait un peu sucré des
fils de maïs qui appeler ça du bien
manger leur convient noël nos desserts
étaient pas sophistiquée du tout c'était
pour remplir c'est pour que personne
n'avait fait un match et on les aime
découvrir justement un petit peu de la
culture de chacun par un vecteur comme
le riz c'est une grande richesse
[Musique]